welcome to the michaela peterson podcast
this is episode 12. for today's episode
i spoke with rob wolf
rob wolff is a former research
biochemist and the two times new york
times best-selling author
of the paleo solution and wired to eat
he's one of the first people i found out
about on the paleo diet scene
years ago i wanted to get rob on the
podcast because he's someone who has an
accurate and reasonable view of a
healthy diet he spent years researching
the actual science behind the paleo diet
and meat consumption
most importantly though he recently
published a book with the dietitian
diana rogers called the sacred
cow which gives readers an accurate
portrayal of all things beef
climate concerns health concerns even
smaller discussions that people don't
really have the facts on
like whether grass-fed beef is really
healthier than grain fed
i hope this podcast episode gives you an
idea of why what we're taught around
meat
particularly beef is inaccurate and
harmful
and hopefully the episode sheds light on
what the science actually points to
if you need a podcast episode to refute
why meat is unhealthy or even bad for
the environment to your overly nosy
in-laws
this is it
[Music]
rob wolfe welcome to my podcast i am
honored to bring down property values on
your podcast thanks for having me
um can you let my audience know a little
bit about who you are and what it is
that you do
yeah so ages ago i was a research
biochemist in the areas of cancer and
autoimmunity
suffered some really really severe
health problems i was eating a
uh high carb low fat vegan diet at the
time and had ulcerative colitis
neurological problems like a whole host
of problems and
in a bit of a a moment of desperation
the
idea that maybe um
grains legumes and and things like that
were not working so well for me
and i did a little bit of research uh
this was 1998
and i went into my house and turned on
the dial up and there was
this new search engine called google at
that time and into google i put the term
paleolithic diet because i had
i'd heard this term back then i have no
idea how it got on my radar
and i found some work from lauren
cordain and art de vani and it was
interesting it
seemed to explain a lot of the problems
that i had ulcerative colitis
inflammation and so i i kind of shifted
gears and started eating in this very
protein-centric
lower carb type of way and uh
for me that was 22 years ago and it was
just nothing short of
of life-changing and i've kind of been
in that that
peri ketogenic you know
keto with paleo food space um
ever since then and i've tinkered and
experimented with a lot of things
interestingly
since folks like yourself have come on
the scene with carnivore
i've actually reduced the amount and
variety of vegetable matter that i
consume and oddly enough my health is
improved one of the interesting
sidelines with
with this is that historically dairy
would give me acne and kind of joint
inflammation like i do brazilian jiu
jitsu and i would really feel it in my
hands
um i now only eat vegetable matter that
i do not get a gi
response from and yeah if i'm okay with
that then i eat
dairy like crazy and i have absolutely
no response to it
so somehow yeah and that's honestly
probably been like the
the most profound refinement that i've
done maybe in the last 10 or 15 years
is just instead of shoehorning vegetable
matter
down my pie hole because i feel like i
need to do it like
really doing it in a targeted fashion
like i seem to do great with
artichokes asparagus melons
most berries cherries
avocado i do terribly with nuts and
seeds which used to be a
a staple of my diet and and now looking
back was
was probably a significant factor so
that's been interesting and i'm always
a fan of eating as broad and inclusive a
diet as one can do
while maintaining health but it's
interesting my health has clearly
improved like my skin's improved my
recovery has improved
um and then sensitivity to things like
dairy has dramatically
like i just don't negatively uh react to
dairy at this point so that's been an
interesting development in the the last
couple of years
wow that's really cool dairy was really
hard on me like when i first went
i went paleo in 2015. uh
and i cut out dairy at the same time
because it was one of the worst triggers
particularly for joint pain and skin
problems but also depression
yep so that's cool yeah yeah yeah and i
had the same kind of complex like kind
of and
and now it's it's gone you know knock on
wood it's gone and i do have one other
factor that changed we moved to
uh new braunfels texas it's very warm
it's not as hot and humid as say like uh
houston or dallas but it it's it's
different we were living in high desert
in in nevada but i get sun on my skin
every day
i get to go swimming every day both in
in pools and
in rivers and that has
improved my health like i can't even
describe so that like photo period
experience like getting sun on my skin
every day you can
you can actually still get a tan here in
uh december like you're low enough
latitude that you can there's still like
a 20 minute window in in december that
you there's enough uv radiation raining
down that you could
you could get a tan for a brief period
of time and that's
arguably been a as big a change as
anything else
that i've done like that's been really
incredible
um interesting yeah okay well for for
people who
so i my audience seems to be pretty
split into two categories
and one are people
who are involved in the kind of idw
space
and the other side is people in the
carnivore or paleo community
so for people who are in the idw space
probably or aren't in the paleo
community
can you describe what the paleo diet is
just in case anyone listening doesn't
know
yeah sure i mean it's it's the for me
it's this perspective
of applying evolutionary biology to
nutrition and it you know it wouldn't be
unreasonable to go out
in an ecological setting and look at an
organism and ask what does it eat how
does it reproduce you know and it in
some basic
questions like that and when we look at
both the anthropological record
and then also some some kind of
suggestive elements of our genetics
it seems like humans are fairly well
designed to eat
a reasonably animal protein centric diet
i would actually at this
point make the argument that we tolerate
plants to the degree that we get
adequate animal nutrition versus the
the other way around um and and i use
this as a
starting point not not as a religious
dogma like it
it's basically kind of calling into
question the most
recently added features to our diet
mainly grains legumes and dairy and and
more recently i would stick just the
general like hyper
processing of our our food system into
kind of a
category unto itself and when we look at
this
interesting phenomenon that we know more
about degenerative disease than we've
ever known in history in 2017
there were over 30 000 peer-reviewed
papers
on the topic of type 2 diabetes so we
know more about these topics than we've
ever known in history but yet their
rates continue to increase and this
just seems like madness like if we were
into building bridges
and we knew more about material science
and
physics and statics we wouldn't make
worse bridges we would make better
bridges and so i i would go out on a
limb and say
that that you know whether my
interpretation of a paleo diet is
accurate or not
shouldn't really be the the litmus test
for whether this topic is accurate the
litmus test should be
is the notion that evolutionary biology
which underpins
all of the you know it's the
foundational tenet of biology
if that is accurate then there must be
some insight to be had
from this kind of darwinian evolution as
it as
you know in forming our nutritional
practices um
i would argue that our health care
system should be effectively free and
not
from kind of like the socialized
medicine perspective but because we
don't
need it other than when we get hit by a
bus or
or you know infectious disease like
we've
chronic degenerative disease should not
be the thing that is killing the most
people on the planet at this stage and
it's because
we've hyper-industrialized our food
system when we've changed
things in such a rapid process that uh
it it's causing really significant uh
morbidity and mortality so
in kind of big picture stuff that's kind
of like the paleo diet concept but it
goes beyond
diet includes photo period and
socialization and gut microbiome and
you know all these different factors
so what would you tell to somebody who
isn't particularly interested in diet
because like
for me even even though i was incredibly
ill diet
and still it's i don't find it that
fascinating of a subject like i'm much
more interested in ideas or something
rather than diet so
a lot of people i speak with are like
who cares
for me like why should i care so what
would you say to those people who cares
about diet
i i actually really appreciate that
perspective um
i often rue the fact that i went into
nutrition because it's basically like a
religious
holy war every day um i really do
like helping people though like i i
legitimately enjoy helping folks a a
kind of missed piece of my background i
guess i co-founded the first and fourth
crossfit affiliate gyms in the world
and i've worked for crossfit hq for
years and i worked with just
tens of thousands of people and i would
have
folks that were suffering these things
that were like genetic diseases you know
porphyria and neurological
symptoms and they would do some really
basic
nutritional tweaks and seemingly put
this stuff into remission and they would
say hey
we've we did the whole round of in vitro
fertilization
and nothing worked and then we changed
her diet and we didn't
we we got pregnant naturally and these
people had spent two hundred thousand
dollars trying to get pregnant before
that and
i all of that stuff is anecdotal but at
some point it's kind of like drop
dropping a hammer on your foot is
anecdotal
you know it's not a randomized control
trial but at some point you're like that
hurts every single time and
i know it hurts and at some point when
you see
these patterns where it's like okay
these folks
have conditions that if i do a little
bit of research it either boils down to
hyperinsulinism
or some sort of a food intolerance or a
combination of those things
and so if you want to live
effectively it makes a lot of sense to
just have some
base level of of a reasonable diet
and for a lot of people they have all
kinds of stuff going on that they've
just
assumed was normal that their post nasal
drip was normal that their
their weird bowel functions were normal
because they've never not
eaten dairy or wheat or what have you
for for longer than like a day at a time
and so
i really like these kind of
paleo-oriented elimination diets because
they allow people to get potentially
back to a base level of health
then we can reintroduce these foods and
see how they do and if it's a problem
then maybe you make the decision to
remove it and if it's not a problem then
no big deal
but it really i i honestly like i like
people who don't give two shits about
diet a lot because it's just
wearying to talk about it but there's
also a lot of people that are
legitimately sick
and so this is kind of my thing which is
um
i'm never going to be the guy that goes
door to door knocking on your door and
like hey can i interest you in the
church of paleo you know that that's not
my
my gig but if somebody has a problem and
they want me to help them
i'll i'll bend over backwards to try to
help them help their family because
there are a lot of people that are
are sick and suffering and having
significant problems and it feels
um morally dodgy
if i do have some information that could
help someone that i
don't do the best job that i can to help
them yeah yeah
yeah that's a solid response i think
that's how i try and go about it
it's like it it doesn't even me
if i'm not actively suffering from some
sort of illness i don't really care but
as soon as you
get hit with being sick it's
all-encompassing and it's horrible so if
people could avoid that
it really perks your ears up a lot yeah
yeah
yeah yeah it's brutal uh so you've
written
three books three books today uh the
payload solution
wired to eat and then i'm not sure when
this is going up but uh tuesday july
14th
we will release the third book that i
co-authored with
my good friend diana rogers called
sacred cow and it looks at the
moral environmental and health
considerations of meat inclusive diet
and food system so why did you guys
decide to
go on that writing journey um
with current social political uh uh
stuff i think that it was a
desire for career suicide and to end any
other options in our lives um were
getting attacked and sailed from
we knew that kind of like the vegan
crowd was going to go after us but we
have people going after us from like
a ridiculous number of directions but
um man how do i say this and not selling
what's going on
oh whatever just say it uh
the main impetus originally on this was
that um
so both of us have kids and and i have
young kids diana has kids that are a
little older than mine
and we wouldn't mind a world that is
both still here and maybe even better
than the world that we lived in and
and this really row crop centric
uh conventional food system that seems
to be pushing like planet of the vegans
as
the only solution to health and
sustainability
when i really started kind of kicking
the tires on this it just didn't make
sense like the the thermodynamics the
energy
inputs and outputs thinking about the
way an ecological system works which
requires both plants
and animals interfacing to make it work
it just didn't make sense and so i i
want to say it was almost 10 years ago
that diana and i
started talking about this in kind of a
public fashion i know you and i met
maybe six years ago now at halo fx was
it that long ago
i mean something like that yeah you had
just had your first
first baby i think i think yeah i just
had scarlet
um okay so no it was four years ago then
four years
okay i think i was or three
four i don't know i think i was already
i can't remember if i was already on the
carnivore diet if i was just paleo i
think i was
on the carnivore diet very very early on
like four months in
yeah so not not as long ago as what i
thought but
we've been talking about this long four
years this stuff it's been a long four
years yeah
it's dog year four years yeah yeah it's
like
it's 7x the the uh you know aging rate
but we just kept adding pieces to the
story you know we would look at
you know like some some discussions
around we're losing all of our top soil
okay well what do we do about that uh
the conventional
industrial ag system is very dependent
on synthetic chemical
fertilizer inputs and what that does to
the topsoil is it makes
all the activity occur right at the the
surface
of the soil and that's terrible for the
microbiome
of the soil of the earth like in a in a
natural grassland
these these root systems can be 10 or 20
feet deep from like a grass blade
and it absorbs sunlight and it pumps
carbohydrates below ground these
carbohydrates
feed both bacteria and fungi that mine
minerals
out of the soil and bring that up into
the plant and then that feeds animals
that grows topsoil and so when we
started looking at these different
features of
does meat cause disease now it doesn't
really look like it it actually seems to
fix a lot of disease
um does the process of grow raising
animals
um disproportionately injure the
environment well
not if you do it in this other way and
then the the ethical piece
is it unethical to eat animals like if i
make a statement i don't want to kill
anything as part of my diet
is that a reasonable position i think
it's a very reasonable position but it's
an impossible position to enact in
practice
because the row crop centric food system
kills enormous amounts of
invertebrates and insects and small
animals and
so when you start equating the animal of
the the life value of a mouse versus a
cow they're both mammals
and we killed just enormous numbers of
mice and birds and whatnot as part of
this industrial row crop food system so
we just started putting together this
this picture and whenever we would have
kind of debates with vegans some of them
formal
some of them informal it's what i call
vegan whack-a-mole where we
they would raise the health question and
you would answer the health question
and then they would raise the
environmental question and you'd answer
the environmental question in various
ways
then they would raise the ethics
question and so we ended up addressing
all of these because i even on the
ethics piece
um it's interesting like social justice
topics or a super
hot thing right now it's fascinating
that a a largely white wealthy
vegan-centric population is telling the
rest of the world
that they are evil and broken if they
have an animal inclusive dietary
practice
but yet the inclusion of animal products
is one of the
most distinguishing factors both in
developing countries
and in in poorer populations in
developed countries
of whether or not their children succeed
or fail academically physically and
socially
the kids that get access to to dense
animal products are
disproportionately likely to succeed
because of neurological development and
in a host of other factors and not
do you have those statistics in the book
we have those statistics in the book and
there there's only been one randomized
control trial done
and this was actually in africa where
they had three different groups of
of children and uh one group they fed a
a meat supplement they they tried to
match calories across the board
the other one was a dairy supplement and
then the other one was just
excess calories and the meat inclusive
group performed far better on
academics on socialization and also on
physical stature and things like
dental development and stuff like that
yeah and interestingly the
the dairy supplemented group did the
worst
of all of them and it's thought that in
that was due
in part to the iron male absorption that
tends to happen
with a very heavy um dairy consumption
the calcium and the dairy
can can inhibit the absorption of of
iron so we have some interesting
examples like that in
uh i know i'm kind of kind of bouncing
all around but there was another thing
that we
discovered in researching the book there
are tens of millions of women around the
world
that legally are unable to own real
estate
or land like culturally legally within
the countries that they live
they can't do it but they can't own
livestock and this is the
sole form of of support
and infrastructure that they have and
it's how they feed their families it's
how they
attain social status and we're now being
told
at levels going from the world health
organization down
that these people are destroying the
planet that they're unethical
in continuing to eat their traditional
food systems and these people
don't have a a rite aid to go to to get
an iron supplement a b
vitamin supplement and a super
critically extracted
dha source from from yeah you know
seaweed so it's interesting i i think
these social justice topics are
rightfully very important but we
sometimes are taking a very simplistic
look at it and
it in this time where people will make a
lot of noise about
cultural appropriation and stuff like
that it's fascinating again
that we're proposing a food system in
which everybody would be dependent on
the row crop
outputs of the united states and europe
primarily
that that we want everybody to abandon
their traditional
food system and just eat the the food
that we largely produce because
there are just enormous numbers of
places around the world where
the only thing that one can produce is
animal products
the you know the area is too rocky or
hilly or it's legitimately a grassland
and it it
literally can't do anything other than
than produce grazing animals and
although we focus a lot
on cattle different areas should use
goats
or sheep or camels or guinea pigs like
it
it depends on the the local environment
the local food systems the local culture
but this is an interesting piece that
the traditional food systems are really
being vilified
because they're animal inclusive but
there is no way to make them work
it unless you shift them into this
synthetic chemical fertilizer system
which then we know
it basically lights a fuse on that that
environment
where the the local ecology
will collapse at some point because of
the degradation of the soil because of
the destruction
of uh insect populations and all these
kind of
you know knock-on uh factors
wow okay well that sounds like it's full
of information uh i never
like delved whenever i give my talks my
talks are always hey
look at what happened to me isn't it
weird now i only eat meat and i don't
have any health problems anymore
huh and then i get somebody in the
audience who's like yeah but what about
the climate and my response is like
my joints aren't disintegrating i don't
really care about the climate like even
if it was
negatively affecting the climate i would
still only be eating meat
because i'm disagreeable and that's my
response but
but a lot of people who reach out say i
would
try this but isn't it bad for the
environment especially
like especially people who are already
vegetarian or vegan or
a lot of i think i find women tend to be
more
upset about the fact that just a
generalization that it might be hard on
the environment so that's interesting
you you talk how do we scale this that's
one of the questions i get asked a lot
is okay that that's fine like eat your
grass-fed beef
but not everyone can get that because
it's not scalable
yeah it's it's interesting and this is a
topic that gets attacked
from quarters that you would expect the
attack like kind of more the
vegan-centric world but even the more
traditionally trained like economists
they're really
enamored with the efficiency of the
current
industrialized row crop kind of kind of
food system
we actually use less land now to produce
the the food that we eat because of this
efficiency but that efficiency is
if you are concerned about greenhouse
gas emissions which is a whole
huge topic like i remind me we'll
we'll unpack more of that a bit later
but if you're concerned about that
it takes enormous amounts of fossil
fuels
to produce the synthetic chemical
fertilizers and the herbicides and the
pesticides that make
that mono crop system work and we know
for a fact it's injurious to the soil
it damages the you know ecological
systems peripheral to this
this food production but it looks really
efficient so long as you ignore
all the other damage that occurs like
the the gulf of mexico is basically a
dead zone now from
all the chemical effluent that makes its
its
way into the the waterways and causes
these algal blooms
so we we've got some some problems there
on on that side but
some of the the really brass tack stuff
is when we look
if we were to divide up all of the land
available for humans to live on and to
grow food upon
and what is available for agriculture
or animal husbandry if we were to
to make a business card that represented
that
two-thirds of that business card that is
available
for food production is amenable only as
grasslands
you can't do anything else with it again
like maybe it's steep or it's rocky or
it's hilly
or or or places like mongolia it's
legitimately a grassland like those
places
are not great at growing crops you can
do a little bit
in some areas but usually you need to to
rotate like you get a year or two of
crop production and then you've got to
bring it back
into grassland so there's a huge chunk
of the planet that is amenable literally
for nothing other than than growing
grass
and the grazing animals that that eat
that grass and then all the other kind
of
ecological functions that that exist
there there's
enormous and we have the exact numbers
detailed in the book on this stuff but
the u.s government pays people to not
produce
meat on land and so the land just sits
fallowing i mean
it is millions and millions of acres of
land
so that's a piece of this story another
piece of the story is that there are
huge tracts of land that have been
desertified they've turned into desert
and we largely write that land off as as
lost
and uh in the film that uh supports this
book we
detail the story of a rancher in the
chihuahuan desert that has restored
tens of thousands of acres of the
chihuahuan desert
to grassland like even people that have
lived in the chihuahuan desert for like
eight generations didn't know that it
was historically a grassland
they didn't know that you could grow
grass there but
you know he has been restoring this
grassland uh
the area that's called the great basin
in the united states from
approximately reno to salt lake city
down to
las vegas used to be grassland but now
it's a desert because it was overgrazed
and it
it was abused and one of the features
that gets
lost in this story is historically these
grasslands had
huge herds of grazing animals that had
predator
interaction constantly and so they would
stay together tightly bunched
they would move through an area and then
they would circle back around
in weeks months or years and
this uh this this mob grazing kind of
kind of
process can be emulated by doing things
like using
um uh portable electric fencing to keep
the animals kind of kind of tightly
bunched and then they move through and
this is different than like the
confined area feed lock this is out on
on grass and
and whatnot but you can emulate the the
impacts that these grazing animals have
on the land which is regenerative
it's like exercise like there's
impact on the land but then the animals
move on and the land
regenerates and becomes stronger as a
process because the animals pee
and poo and break up the soil and then
dung beetles move in and
you know there's this whole ecological
process so
we have land that is off use because of
governmental subsidies telling people to
not raise food on it
we have land that is desertified that
can be regenerated
and we can grow food on it and then in
our current
model folks don't oftentimes realize
this but
the cows even that are are raised in the
the kfo model like a confined area
feedlot model your walmart meat
they spend 85 to 90 percent of their
lives on grass
and and this is a like the energy inputs
on this are a whole other
whole other you know important topic to
to unpack
but it wouldn't take that much effort to
just kind of shove that system over
into a fully regenerative process and
when we look at some outlets like
polyface farms they get about four to
five hundred percent more productivity
out of their land than the people around
them
um when we look at more desertified or
brittle areas
the productivity is around 30 to 50
percent better so in in the book
we detail all the unused land all of the
areas that can be
uh rehabilitated and then we make the
case that conservatively
we can improve production about 30 to 50
percent
above what we do today on animal
husbandry
and so that that's kind of the the
backbone of you know where this story
could scale
and this is wow still even looking at a
very
um monochromatic element like we
really should in these herds have cattle
and and uh sheep
and goats and camels and you know we
should be using different animals in
different environments like cattle
really aren't that well
adapted for the west they're they're
they're derived from uh
asiatic areas that have more water and
the impact they have on the land is
not as good as what it could be like in
the americas it should be bison like it
really should be bison bison is good too
yeah it's amazing but um ten thousand
years
ago there were three species of elk in
the great
great plains and the the great basin or
not elk but uh camels
not that much longer ago there were
elephants in the americas and
and with the introduction of the the how
long ago
10 15 000 years ago camels
camels yeah it's crazy that's cool
yeah and i mean horses used to be
indigenous to the americas and then they
went extinct here
and they were reintroduced and and so
that's a another example of
of these you know large herds of of
grazing animals so
the the flip side of this story when you
really look at the impacts the negative
impacts of the conventional
food system the question is how does
that
go on for a thousand years it can't i
mean
nobody said nobody says it can and so
at some point like this regenerative
practice
is the thing that we're going to have to
use and
if humanity is still here a thousand
years from now
it's not going to be growing meat in a
lab
it's not going to be this really heavily
uh row crop
centric food system it's going to be
some sort of a small
decentralized food production system
that takes advantage of the
economies of scale of food centralized
distribution
so it's not that costco and walmart goes
away but the bulk of the food gets eaten
on a more
regional basis and then the excess gets
gets consolidated
and kind of shipped around so there's a
huge amount of elasticity within that
system that we just
aren't really thinking about or or using
currently but ironically if you go most
other places around the world this is
the way their systems function the
united states
is kind of uh an anomaly because of the
way
you know global reserve currency and a
bunch of other stuff but like
if you go to australia and you order a
steak
and they have an option between regular
steak and grain finished steak the grain
finished steak
is more expensive because it requires
more energy inputs
and the fact that it appears cheaper in
the united states is just an artifact of
our kind of subsidy system
wow so theoretically uh the amount of
land that
let me tell me if i have this wrong uh
the amount of land that isn't being used
properly now or is
in desert form could be converted and we
could have different forms of herd
animals
in those areas in the states a lot of
unused land and really globally yeah
yeah wow so this book sounds like it
should get into the hands of somebody in
the government
who's who that actually like can
implement not that anyone apparently
apparently laws in the government are
mostly written by you know that
21 year olds taking notes and everyone
else is out
having dinners with each other right
that's what i've heard anyway
but you know an ironic feature of all
this stuff
is that the biggest pushback we've had
against this kind of row crop centric
food system has been coming from
developing countries
where these folks are like there's no
way we can make that work here like it
will destroy
our traditional food systems we would be
wholly dependent
on the exports of places like the united
states or
or europe and so you know these
recommendations that have come from like
eat landsat
and the world health organization have
been criticized pretty
pretty soundly but also people saying we
will not enact these
these measures are coming from
developing countries yeah
yeah wow okay that's interesting i'm
going to throw some questions at you
that
can arm people when they get attacked
for their meat eating
um well i guess the main thing we should
cover
is aren't cows ruining the environment
like what about
you know methane carbon about that
problem
so this is a great one and it uh
uh some of the idw people might might
appreciate this but i had a friend
who helped me with my first book uh
super smart person um acknowledged her
in my first book
and then she she had i posted something
about shellfish producing huge amounts
of methane
there was an article in the journal
physics talking about
the the fact that they just discovered
that these these shellfish populations
produce
absolutely prodigious amounts of methane
and the some of the discussion there was
do we need to go in and expunge these
things
and i was just like that's crazy we're
killing life to protect life and one of
these basic
tenets of ecology and one of the things
that's being thrown around currently is
we're in the sixth mass extinction and
all these animals are disappearing
and now we have people recommending that
like there was a a
vote in parliament which didn't make it
but in sweden to
exterminate the moose population because
the moose belch
methane and so this this and you
shouldn't find that funny because it's
real
it's crazy to me like it seems so
obviously wrong but it's
really a lot to unpack it's literally
like ecology
physics thermodynamics and this is why
it's hard to unpack this stuff
there's a lot going on and folks don't
really have the attention span for it
frequently but
i said to this friend i i had posted
this article
on the shellfish i'm like hey it's
important that we have a nuanced
conversation around the climate change
topic particularly greenhouse gases
because if we get this wrong we're going
to make a bunch of really terrible
decisions that are going to be difficult
to
to unfuck them in in the future
and she said to me i've noticed anybody
that doesn't accept the
standard climate change narrative that
they are typically also a holocaust
denier
now this is this is someone i've known
for a decade they got acknowledged in my
first book and all i'm saying is like
hey let's pump the brakes here
and have a careful discussion around
this and this is where this stuff has
kind of been
weaponized you know where uh okay now
i'm a nazi and a holocaust denier for
saying that we should have
a nuanced discussion around this and
this is where it gets really
important cows do produce methane but
the methane the biological systems and
the carbon dioxide that's released via
biological systems
it is released and then re-sequestered
and released and re-sequestered
and it's it's not a net
total input to the system the net total
input to the system
is largely from the transportation you
know sector and
and uh energy production and whatnot and
the
irony there when when you look at the
life cycle analysis
of grass produced meat and the life
cycle analysis
is this huge kind of physics and
engineering process of looking at
all the inputs all the outputs the total
life cycle analysis for
properly raised holistically managed
grass-fed beef
is that it's car net carbon negative it
removes more carbon out of the
environment
then it releases and this is part of
what grows
grasslands and and produces topsoil and
and
that's an interesting system how is that
possible if cows are releasing methane
then how can the net
value b you're explaining that grass-fed
meat if it's done properly is a carbon
sink carbon negative
yeah so how is that possible this goes
back to that interface
of the grasslands and the action that's
happening below the
the ground the the microbiome below the
ground
so when the grass uh captures sunlight
it uh converts the sunlight into
uh carbohydrates some of that
carbohydrate
goes into growing the plant itself some
of that carbohydrate goes below
the the surface into the root beds to
feed bacteria and fungi
these bacteria and fungi create products
that it's called like
hummus and and it's these um
complex organic molecule structures that
is basically this the underpinning of
topsoil
there's minerals that are mined in that
process but also it's it's the carbon
that is extracted out of the atmosphere
that is the backbone for this carbon and
people will dismiss this because if you
look at an area that has
um that has been mistreated soil that's
been mistreated
it may have a carbon content as low as
like point
five percent of its its dry weight
and then when it is rehabilitated it
will top
off at about five percent of dry weight
which is a
you know ten times increase and people
will then dismiss that
but what happens is you can continue
building more
topsoil so that's not an end state this
process will continue to grow that that
topsoil
and that topsoil is made of carbon
so when people are talking about
different things like liquefying carbon
dioxide and pumping it underground
we do that on grasslands and even things
like peat bogs and
things like that they release methane
but they
net net sequester more carbon than
methane is released
and although methane is a more potent
greenhouse gas
it has a reasonably short life cycle as
part of this kind of biogenic process
and interestingly also when the
soil is is healthy there are
methanotrophic bacteria that consume the
methane
so just because it is belched out or
just because it's part of a cow patty
doesn't mean that all of that methane
actually stays in the environment some
of it is is used as a
food substrate and you know the the
thing about this is that if we
vilify greenhouse gases just uniformly
and we're like we must reduce their
production
at all costs then we start doing things
like exterminating
termite mountains or around the world
which would be catastrophic they produce
enormous amounts of greenhouse gases
these shellfish
peat bogs and now we're discovering that
even things like
rice production is arguably a larger
greenhouse gas emitter
than the the animal husbandry side of
this
that's why people are attacking you yeah
yeah i mean
it it and again like there's an
asymmetric war that is fought here
where folks on this kind of row crop
centric kind of vegan-centric model
they'll say
meat causes cancer meat gives you heart
disease meat destroys the environment
and maybe they have some studies that
kind of support this but it seems really
compelling and it's
really easy it's an elevator pitch thing
people have an attention span for that
and i mean i've floundered around for 15
minutes trying to unpack the
the methane and greenhouse gas story
like it's
it's tough to get your arms around and
so this uh kind of asymmetric warfare
that's going on is really challenging
to get out in in front of but it's as
i the point that i tried to make to this
this friend of mine
it's critical that we talk about this
and get it right because
if we just uniformly vilify greenhouse
gas emissions then we're going to make
decisions that are
terrible for our food system terrible
for
the global economic system and
ultimately will be terrible for both
people
and the environment wow well i think you
did a good job explaining the card
thank you i understood that so probably
five people have committed suicide
listening to this so far
so it's like i i give up i'm done
um okay what about the water argument
that
uh me the water argument is use a whole
bunch of it yes
you know the water argument it's great
and it's honestly a little bit easier to
unpack
there was a great article that was
published out of scandinavia that looked
at this accounting of all the water that
goes into making
meat versus beets versus wheat and all
this stuff
so they break water into three different
categories
green water blue water and gray water
the green water is water that falls on
the the earth as
rain it it's or or snow or or you know
mist what have you but it's some sort of
precipitation
blue water is water from lakes streams
and below ground aquifers and gray water
is the effluent side like the water that
comes out of
different systems what was fascinating
about the paper
the paper concluded that meat was what
they called a water hog
but what was fascinating about that is
in the case of
wheat and beets and and things like that
the water that fell
on the earth was not seen
as being detrimental it wasn't taking
away from things but when they did the
accounting on the meat
they accounted it as if we were stealing
water from somewhere else
but this is water that just falls on the
earth
grows grass and it it's gonna fall no
matter what and if we have a healthy
grassland it actually retains more
water like a healthy patch of dirt
can retain a hundred times more water
than an unhealthy patch of
which the water just runs off and it
erodes the top topsoil and whatnot
and so it was interesting that the the
study authors
had a conclusion that actually wasn't
supported by their data like they were
unfairly um lumping these things
together and so i i forget the exact
numbers on the breakdown but
even in in pastured meat 96 to 98
percent of the water is green water
it is water that falls on the earth it
was going to fall on the earth
it's good that it falls on the earth
it's part of these grasslands
conventionally raised meat was something
like 92 percent green water
and then there were varying mixes of
blue water inputs and then how much
gray water effluent was produced out of
that but the
the water usage piece is really um
it's it's some really bad
accounting and it very poorly paints a a
picture around what the
you know the water usage is for for
grazing animals a similar story
and this is probably a question you were
going to ask is that we're
we're uh stealing food from humans in
the form of grains and
and you know like soy and feeding it to
animals yeah i was gonna do that one too
one piece to that is that we are not
lacking in our ability to produce
calories
this is actually a problem we have we
produce plenty of calories we don't
produce adequate
nutrition um the only reason why anybody
is hungry in this day and age is
distribution and political factors like
we produce enough food but arguably we
may not
produce enough nutrition and when you
really talk about human nutrition
animal centric protein is kind of where
the rubber hits the road
like it is very difficult to
tick all of the boxes of getting
appropriate nutrition
without animal uh inputs and
particularly if we're
actually going to not overeat there's
this uh concept the protein leverage
hypothesis
that suggests that most animals eat to a
protein minimum
and and the thought there is that most
protein dense foods
are disproportionately nutrient dense
and so if you get enough protein by
extension you get enough nutrition by
nutrition
it's essential amino acids essential
fatty acids vitamins and minerals
and a great paper was was done that
looked at
what would happen if we removed all
animal products out of the american food
system
and it would only reduce our greenhouse
gas emissions by about 2.5 percent
but it said that we would have increased
nutrient deficiencies and people would
overeat because of the protein
malnutrition in that story
that's a piece of this thing another
piece of this thing is that the vast
majority of
the grains fed to animals are the
products that are left over
after ethanol production and this is
ethanol both
both for for like fuel additives which
is a complete boondoggle it takes more
energy to make that than you get out of
it
the ethanol farmers don't drive the
tractors with ethanol because it costs
more energy than what they get out of it
so that's a
total boondoggle but then you know
breweries wineries all that type of
stuff all of that
food potential food gets
fed to animals which seems like a
reasonable thing but it is portrayed as
if that is
stealing food away from other humans now
this is specific to
cattle when we look at chickens and pork
they are fed almost exclusively a grain
mainly corn but a grain and soy based
diet
so if you want to make a credible
argument around
well you're you're taking resources away
and it and it's energy intensive
chicken and pork are arguably like you
could make a solid case for that but
even in
uh kfo produced meat it spends 85 to 90
percent of its life
on grass but the interesting thing is as
we've we've gone
through time we eat less beef and and
lamb and
and things like that and we eat more
chicken
and in leonardo dicaprio's film before
the flood
he he you know decries all the problems
of animal husbandry and then his
solution that he makes at the end is to
eat more chicken
which from from an ecological input
perspective
is nuts like if you really want to have
a discussion around like well we're
it's expensive and energy intensive to
produce these grains then you're feeding
them to
to chickens like that's a pretty
credible uh place to be made but that's
the recommendation that he's making and
this is how disconnected people are from
these systems and don't really
understand the inputs and outputs
wow yeah well it's a lot easier to make
a case
you know cows are cute
let's not keep them because that's cruel
yeah um compared to actually looking at
the physics behind it like
those are on completely different levels
you can get a like a two-year-old to say
they don't want to eat a cow because
it's cute but
right right right yeah
uh okay so that's good if anyone needs
to be armed or needs advice on why meat
should be good for you
or what you could be doing for the
environment or how meat
practices should be changed i would
recommend checking out the book because
that's completely full of information
we did a pretty cool thing where we went
through and made lists of
will meat give you cancer we tackle that
on this page
you know and so we have this list of
these so you just kind of
topic so that if somebody gets
kind of kind of
pinged with it and you know it's
i know we probably got something wrong
in the book maybe we're completely 100
wrong with the the book maybe it's
farcical
and the planet of the vegans is the only
way that this stuff is going to work
but we honestly really tried we started
off with some basic
premises and then we did everything we
could
to nuke those ideas like we really
that's how you're supposed to do science
science yeah yeah and and we had some
interesting things there that were some
zingers that would have been nice if
they had gone
different for us like the we have been
besieged by people in the regenerative
ag scene
when you look at the nutritional content
the nutritional density of
conventionally raised meat versus
grass-fed meat there's just not that big
of a difference
and like we tortured the information
like i
i got all ansel keys on it and tried to
tweak it every way we could
and it and it was funny i just i was
i was like out how is this doing
this and then i j it just struck me i'm
like
oh meat uniformly
is nutritious that's the problem you
know
like that's that's the problem and there
are
ethical considerations for why pastured
meat would be better there are
definitely environmental considerations
for why pastured meat would be better
i think there are some credible concerns
around like bioaccumulation
like feeding um uh tainted
grain to animals can bioaccumulate
everything from like
aflatoxin from mold and infested grains
to
atrazine which is you know a part of the
industrial food system
but that's a separate topic from
nutrition nutrition is like vitamins
minerals amino acids fatty acids and
whatnot
and people will get all wrapped around
the axle that grass-fed meat has more
omega-3s than grain-fed meat
but the amount of omega-3s in
literally a pinky-sized piece of salmon
is as much as like eight pounds of
grass-fed beef
so it it just doesn't matter and if if
you're really going to die on that hill
then you can never
eat a handful of almonds ever because
then you just flipped
the omega-3 omega-6 ratio into an
unfavorable direction
so we've been hammered by by people
that are really angry with us they're
like this just can't be true and it
we have looked at every scrap of
information that section we actually
hired an independent researcher
to we did all the research and we're
like we want
you independently to go out and do this
analysis
and just start from scratch don't use
any of our information
he arrived at exactly the same
conclusion we did
which either means that's true or we're
all idiots which is
is possible but it it's um it would have
played to our story much better to say
oh yeah grass-fed meat is way more
natural yeah
oh yeah it would have it would have
played really better that's
i'm one of the no sean baker too but i'm
one of the
people in the carnivore sphere that says
just eat meat because
it hasn't made a bit of aged meat can
give me issues
but that's it right grass-fed even corn
fed
and i don't really like the taste of
corn fed but even corn fed beef if
that's what you can afford that hasn't
given me a flare or anything so it just
seems like beef is okay
like lamb is okay it's been because i
tried to do grass-fed only for a while
to see if there was some magical health
benefit but i didn't notice
at all so that's yeah that's really
interesting it's good that you have
that you actually went into the research
too and didn't just cater to
one side when we did the outline
initially it was grass-fed meat is
more nutritious than grain-fed meat like
that was part of our
outline we assumed that that was true
that like i have
spouted that narrative in the past and
it's because there is a study that says
that it's got more omega-3 fats
what i neglected to look at was that
it's a paltry amount of omega-3s one way
or the other you know it just didn't
matter like if you really cared about
that then have a piece of fish
like that that's not where you're gonna
win that war so we started off in the
outline
with a a different line item but again
we got in we're like okay is this really
true let's look at the data and
it wasn't true there cool
okay um let's see
i don't have a lot more time we're
running out so i think the main
i think okay we'll switch that we'll
switch topics a bit
uh for somebody who's looking who's on
the standard american diet or whatever
the diet they're following
what are the main foods you would
suggest people
stay away from in order to get healthier
in the least restrictive way possible
and i guess least restrictive is really
relative because i've seen some people
that like they hadn't eaten
anything that wasn't in a box or a can
in ages
so it but you know i mean just avoiding
processed
highly processed foods if it's got a box
with a bunch of
ingredients in it it's probably going to
be a
a problem i would argue that just you
know people
there's all this back and forth on like
is low fat better is low carb better
when folks demonize high fat
it's usually in the context of like seed
oils
wrapped into some sort of like corn and
wheat products
that are then massaged in a way to make
them hyper palatable like they taste
absolutely amazing the lay's potato chip
tagline is
bet you can't eat just one you know and
like i'll i'll take that bet
all day long and so avoiding processed
foods
i i guess really if i had my feet held
to the fire in like one thing
liquid carbohydrates like soda and juice
seems to be absolutely the devil and so
like if you were to switch to diet soda
and like your kids
don't need to drink juice it's not good
for them give them a piece of fruit
like so if you really held my feet to
fire and said what's one thing that you
would do
um don't drink sugar sweetened beverages
would probably be the the hill that i
would try to die on with that
interesting yeah i mean sparkling water
is good water
just just don't put um a super critical
uh dissolving level of sugar
into it and then yeah yeah yeah yeah
you know before i went paleo i didn't
like water
how funny huh isn't that weird like i
didn't like the taste i i kind of liked
sparkling water
kind of but i didn't drink i hardly
drank any water i drank juice and milk
and diet coke well i i don't know if it
was you or your dad but one of you said
you know when you're down to beef
and salt and water the distinction
between hot medium
cold water bubbly or not bubbly becomes
like really important
so yeah yeah salty not salty right
right yeah yeah yeah um
okay where can people find you online uh
if the you know the main place that uh
all of this information is
is existing is sacredcow.info
um depending on when this airs folks who
pre-order the book
are in queue to to get all kinds of cool
swag and we're gonna have some other
things going on with that but
i would mainly go there like i have this
um other
membership site called the healthy
rebellion if people are interested in in
hanging out with
very geeky people who talk about this
stuff a lot then
that's a that's a good place to check
out but that's kind of the the main
places um
the google algorithm last year made my
website basically disappear from the
interwebs it's still there but
wow it gets uh 97 less traffic than it
did last year so
you're kind of a private investigator if
you can find it at this point
so yeah wow that's frustrating yeah that
was fun
yeah uh is the healthy rebellion also a
podcast
it is that is the name of my podcast
also yeah yeah
cool okay well i'll put all those links
below so people can find you
but thank you very much for coming on
that was informative and i
i actually learned some things too
because like i said i haven't really
been that interested in looking into
i've looked into climate a bit just so i
can have some retorts to people but
i think that was a that was a that was
good so thank you for coming on
you know there is a little bit of irony
in that though almost out of a
ann randian kind of perspective which is
if you just take care of you then all
the other gets dealt with
and then when you become a busybody
trying to steward everybody else this is
where we end up in a really
significant problem and so like you
addressing your health issues is
ironically assuming we're right the best
thing for you
the best thing for the environment you
know like it has all these kind of
fascinating knock-on effects so
yeah i applied you on that it's actually
a
a remarkably well-informed place to be
so i that's great oh thank you thank you
i guess that that's what my dad tries to
say with clean your bedroom right
yeah yeah totally start there yeah
okay well thanks for coming on rob
mikayla thanks yeah i hope to see you
again in real life here
at some point yeah in the next next five
years or so
exactly
[Music]
you